and so women will wear these trashy
outfits that clearly men are going to
want to look and then they get mad that
when they look it's like what did you
think was going to happen it's like
women are fighting for equality I know
people hate that right I'm not a
feminist sometimes I do have feminist
ways I'm not a feminist but I do believe
that you should have the right to wear
what you want if I want to go I'm going
to be hot in a gym right so why can't I
work out in something that small what am
I supposed to wear sweatpants and a
night gown yeah to out because men can
control their eyes respect people who
you can you can wear what you want but
don't whine about the consequences